Marvel's defenders unites it's for
street-level heroes daredevil Jessica
Jones Luke Cage and iron fist against
the forces of the hand and like any good
Marvel production it's got plenty of
hidden easter eggs cameos cool backs and
in jokes you became review lovers it's
Jan here and today I'm revealing some of
the best Easter eggs moments and
connections in the defenders my giveaway
for our defenders or Punisher Funko pop
is also running on this video so
subscribe and keep watching to find out
how to win and justify delve in be aware
I will be discussing spoilers please
cage has certainly earned a reputation
with the ladies in these Netflix shows
starting with Jessica Jones in the first
season of her series after they broke up
Nuka moved to Harlem where his
adventures on his own show gave life to
a series of Luke Cage coffee memes which
picks up on his and other characters use
of the word coffee as a euphemism for
sex and the defenders includes a clever
wink to this in joke by the single
origin copy post as you can spot behind
Luke Cage when he meets with misty
Knight in the Luke Cage series after
misty asked him out for coffee and he
confessed he didn't like it they ended
up sleeping together that coffee joke
continues in another defenders episode
with a copy post to place behind Luke
while he talks to Claire temple 3
previously asked out for coffee and Luke
Cage but she refused saying she wasn't
going to sleep with him and intriguingly
in the final episode of the defenders
jessica says to Luke that maybe we'll
grab a coffee sometime or something so
perhaps we'll even see Luke and Jessica
back together at some point in the
future and during that conversation
between Luke and Claire she gives him
the name of the bar where he then goes
to interrogate Turk the bars named
trouble and a pair of dice previously
appeared in an old New York bulletin
newspaper that Karen page was sifting
through in daredevil season 2
during Jessica Jones as investigations
at the records office there's a nod to
hand villain Nobu who was rumored to
have lived three lifetimes back in the
second season of daredevil one of the
files Jessica stumbles across is for a
corporation called Yoshioka which is
Nobu surname and in the comics with
cassia Nobu Yoshioka who founded the
villainous organization the hands and in
other hand related matters we all know
Marvel loves to chop off hands and arms
in its phase 2 movies as an homage to
Star Wars but like other
Netflix shows before it defenders
includes its own limb losing WTF moment
when stick chops off his own hand to
escape Alexandra's clutches you could
say there's a bit of ironic symbolism
here and that he has to cut off his own
hand to escape the villainous groups a
hand interestingly also this moment is
probably a callback to the time that
sticks sliced off a hand villains hand
in the first season of daredevil
speaking of losing limbs remember how in
season 1 of Luke Cage misty Knight
injured her arm during the hostage siege
at Harlem's paradise well that was a
hint the comics where her character
loses an arm during a bomb attack but
season 1 of the defenders took that hint
and made it reality when Misty's arm was
lopped off at Midland Circle while she
was battling the hand alongside Colleen
wing now comic book misty was given a
bionic arm by Tony Stark and it seems
she's being set up to something similar
on the show too however I'm guessing it
will be a different billionaire who will
be responsible for giving misty a
super-powered limb in the defenders
verse given the fact that at the end of
the season she's shown recuperating at a
state-of-the-art hospital owned by rich
boy Danny R and I think misty will have
Danny and his connections as Colleen
refers to them to thank for her new
Bionic arm the patient care board in
Misty's hospital room also includes a
couple of hidden Marvel Easter eggs
first is the name al Carter short for
Lynda Carter a nurse in the comics who
specialized in taking care of injured
superheroes and took on the alias of
light nurse also listed as dr. wertham
an Easter Egg to Elias wertham a doctor
in the comics who ended up becoming a
vigilante an antihero called cardiac I
wonder whether we'll see where them turn
up as a character who fits Misty's new
bionic arm or if this is just an easter
egg plain and simple on the subject of
misty I've got a fare love seeing her
hand Colleen her katana at the police
station in a nice bit of foreshadowing
of their fight scene on the show and
also of their partnership in the comics
of course it was pretty cool seeing
misty and Colleen battle alongside each
other in the series and a hat tip to
their comic book team-up as the
daughters of the Dragon plus Colleen's
white top and Misty's ready orange one
echo their costumes in the comic books
and as Miss used you to appear in season
two of iron fist it's fair to say we'll
be seeing a lot more of her and Colleen
together and since the known mystic and
Jessica hello wake up
excellent in their respective roles this
can only be a good thing
Shanley makes a cameo in the show with a
similar NYPD picture to ones we've seen
in many of his other Marvel Netflix
cameos this particular poster adds a
nice touch though with the line not all
heroes work ape and not the show
street-level heroes obviously none of
whom were capes and the show really gets
into its stride in the third episode
when it busts out an epic corridor scene
after all four heroes finally team up to
take on the hand at Midland Circle
corridor fight scenes are a staple of
Marvel's Netflix show then this one has
a pretty spectacular ending with iron
fist using his punch to shatter
Electra's blade the show tips its house
in a couple of ways to the mythical
dragon Danny Rand had to defeat in order
to become the iron fist there's the name
of the restaurant the Royal dragon were
the defenders retreat - after their
first Midland circle battle an iron fist
origins are also referenced in several
jokes between Claire Colleen Luke and
Danny about how crazy all his talk about
dragons is by the way it's great to see
how the cinematography and production
design from all the solo shows really
come together in the defenders for
example just look at how the colors
associated with daredevil Jessica Jones
Luke Cage and iron fists are reflected
in the sign for the Royal dragon
restaurant where the defenders team-up
as well as in the lighting and fixtures
and fittings inside the restaurant
there are also a few cool shoutouts to
Game of Thrones which is fitting as both
Finn Jones and Jessica Henrik starred in
the HBO fantasy series of course it's a
nice coincidence that there's lots of
talk of dragons in both shows even if
the Marvel shows don't have the budget
to put them on display in the way that
Thrones does more intriguing me though
is the appearance in the defenders of
two lines that have found their way into
everyday language thanks to their
popularity in Game of Thrones
during the Midland Circle battle one
bakuto is about to bring his sword down
on 3rd evel's colleen wing blocks bakuto
with her own sword and as she does so
she utters the line not today which is
Syrio Forel classic retort to the god of
death in Game of Thrones and in episode
8 Elektra says to Matt you know nothing
something Ygritte often used to tell Jon
Snow on Game of Thrones there's a cool
spider-man Easter Egg via the lyrics of
the wu-tang clan
protect your neck which plays during the
final fight scene and includes the line
swinging through your town like your
neighborhood spider-man at the end of
the season this scene of Matt Murdock
bandaged in bed a bedside table and
window either side of him across above
him and a nun sitting by his side
strongly echoes this image from
daredevil issue 230 the fact the show
chose to include that huge visual easter
egg has potentially massive consequences
for events in the next season of
daredevil and I'll talk in lots more
detail about that in my upcoming video
what we can expect in daredevil season 3
and the final defenders episode also
includes a post-credits teaser for the
new Punisher series with lots of Frank
Castle Easter eggs and references I've
made a full video breakdown of that
which you can watch by tapping the top
right of the screen here and there's
also a link to that in the video
description below and at the end of this
video now which were your favorite
Easter eggs or moment in the defenders
and are there any other Easter eggs or
connections you spotted in the series be
sure to leave a comment and subscribe
for a chance to win an awesome defenders
or Punisher Funko pop I'll announce the
winner on an upcoming video so turn on
your notifications to make sure you see
that if you enjoyed this your likes and
shares is hugely appreciated as all your
suggestions for future videos speaking
of which why not check out more of my
multiple videos right here thanks for
watching and see you next time you
became Ruby lovers